you're doing black you're feeling great
uh-huh I love that show you're also
hosting yes a game show to tell the
truth yes yes and you have a new talk
show yes for Animal Planet why are you
doing so much ah three reasons before I
like expensive things
uh-huh my daughter is in private college
my son is in private school and my
mother is a chronic gambler and addicted
to bingo that's where the majority of
the money goes my mother's bingo habit
exactly are you talking about this
before that is real you know he loses
money on bingo and you got to cover the
car every day for the last I'm 46 for
the last 36 37 years right loses money
every day at every day and will not
learn her lesson will not learn her
lunch money can you lose it bingo though
oh man oh yeah that's like eight cards
boys she plays 6co she plays two cards
that has six games each so 12 cards 12
it's the crazy thing
your mom's quite a character you've
talked about her yes uh-huh and I heard
that your mom brings autographed
pictures of herself everywhere she goes
is that true she does she does because
she thinks it's about her and I was like
mom and nobody cares that you're my
mother she said no they'd be asking me
for these pictures so like I've bought
it to her last picture this is her last
[Applause]
she go to Kinko's total copies a
thousand at a time mm and passes them
out on the street brief I'm pre-signed
mama doris day and she gets a thousand
made and she passes the modernist and do
people asked remember to shake your
hands if any Anderson's mama huh yeah
but but now that she's my co-host or my
sidekick on on my game show to tell the
truth she's getting recognized for that
right she gives them out for that she
was smart she started giving out the
headshots before she be honest and then
they caught up but they raided an
audience
you